getting back to like the habits and the
things you uh believed even if you know
science is like disproved there like do
you guys have like any like wives tales
or like anything that any habits that
was formed from basically at a childhood
age where like your parents said
something oh yeah and you like you you
did it as a kid because you your mum or
dad said so dude dude i have a japanese
grandma they are nothing but wife
like okay so like to this day like
whenever i get ill right i eat a [ __ ]
ton of oranges right like i eat like a
pack of oranges oranges
and like because because when i was
young um my mum said oh vitamin c is
good for the immune system
i don't know where that came from i'm
pretty sure there is some science back
to it but like i think i've read into it
once and yes vitamin c does improve the
immune system but that's like one i
believe okay this is this is all my
memory so you know feel please fact
check this
it also might have just been gone's
health it might it might have just been
my my household but one i believe that's
to like
like prevent illness so it like boosts
your immune system so it's more a more
healthy immune system and two there's
only so much
vitamin c intake you can uh you can you
can do
to really have a big effect on your
immune system so but like that doesn't
matter in my mind because in my mind i'm
like i've been conditioned to think i am
ill i need to eat a [ __ ] ton of oranges
to intake this vitamin c
to have these [ __ ] basically just
like a pavlovian thing yeah yeah yeah
right right it's like cough swamps where
are the oranges
that's so weird because in my house it
was if you were starting to get sick or
you were sick my mom and my granda my
grandma especially my grandma would make
me eat a shitload of ginger and spring
onion
i don't know why
um
it just it just seems like a healthy
alternative but yeah it's just one of
those things where it has that taste to
it that you're like this has to be
helpful
i don't know why but this has to be
because it's causation
because it tastes like medicine yeah
like it tastes like medicine before even
like being put in a dish you know yeah
another one i had a lot was uh like if i
got like a cut on like my knee or
something yeah uh then you'd uh my
grandma would tell me to put wasabi on
it what what the [ __ ]
that's a very famous japanese one though
a lot of a lot of uh what that's a very
famous where did that come from i don't
know maybe it's because like you know
when you put like an antiseptic on right
and it starts to sting yeah but that
means it's like killing the bacteria
right so someone probably thought well
wasabi does that regularly is that where
the stinging i don't think i think the
singing is part of killing bacteria i
think she's like no
i don't know if that's even a wife tell
either but like i did i did like when i
was little like you know i i was running
around in the park and then i [ __ ]
slid and scratched my knee
and you know it was fine until i got
home and my grandmother was like oh [ __ ]
we gotta patch you up dog so then she
went into the kitchen and i was like uh
the bandages are over here she's like no
no no i got this
pulls out a [ __ ] chewable wasabi and
i was like
grandmother what are you doing oh no no
no no no and she's like all right just
just hold still like [ __ ] pulls you
know squirt someone to a finger and just
starts like rubbing my knee oh and uh
that [ __ ] hurts
no [ __ ] like a lot and uh
you know
i wouldn't exactly say it worked um if
anything it just added an extra step of
oh now it hurts and i have to shower to
get that and it burns now and it burns
my
my regular skin that's not affected by
the cut
yeah so that was the moment i was like
grandma you should probably like you
know
read up on like some you know basic
first aid i'm just wondering where that
started from because like i can imagine
it's something similar to like putting
salt on a wound right which is you know
it's uh it sterilizes the wound uh
as well as it could as well as it could
do does it i thought it was just painful
no it does i think we google this
by the way is
somewhat antibacterial okay yeah but if
i pissed on your leg it'd be somewhat
antibacterial problem is that this is
the problem
when you when when these things get some
form of like it's like yeah you're one
percent right one percent right
right i heard right i heard right i
better add that to my five-minute daily
life
yeah is is salt uh like a like a kind of
like an anticipated supposedly it
creates conditions that make it
difficult for bacteria to grow
supposedly written by the same person
i thought salt in the wound was you did
that because you want to like
be painful like you would like torture
someone what
what do you mean well you think it's
like people in the painting that's why
we say salt on the wound because it's
like all right let's say i [ __ ] you
over to put salt in the wound i'll do it
but it didn't do it to [ __ ] someone over
it is it is painful but i'm pretty sure
where do they originate from salt on the
wound can you google this i'm pretty
sure it's not meant it's not medical
already it's like it's to add more pain
to it i think it came from like salty's
like a preserver right so it kind of
makes it hard for bacteria to grow it
preserves the wound
this is complete [ __ ] you're making
this up now guys actually i don't know
where i know this from [ __ ] the idiom
means
break your mother's back no that is not
how that works it just rhymes do you
think that well things happen to exist
because they rhyme
i i'm actually curious where okay is is
it so
does putting salt in a wound make it
worse at all does it do anything doesn't
make it hurt more yeah i know that i
know that
i know that more but it's also like you
know it makes it difficult for bacteria
is so vague though that's like there's a
different scene of treatment and
something yeah just put some antiseptic
on it sure if i cut my leg off it'd be
harder for me to walk like i'm you know
it's put some just put some salt
that's why like you wash wounds with
like saline solution as well yeah you
don't do it with salt
yeah but sailing solution is saltwater
yeah it's saltwater that's if you don't
put like you're not putting on those
like the [ __ ] rocks rubbing it in
there we're done
that's not what i said
the saying isn't put saline on them
if i'm like lost in the wilderness or
something and i'm like fighting like
[ __ ] miles away from civilization put
some rocks on yeah just just like just
like right
now
and just like just sprinkle it on
sprinkle japan japan though is full of
so many of those kinds of idioms taking
medical advice from idioms oh no no
but like there's a lot of like idioms
like that especially in japan where it's
like you know one of them that my
grandma used to tell me all the [ __ ]
time was like don't whistle at night
because snakes will come yeah and it
wasn't until a couple years later i
found out snakes are deaf so
yeah and then i started whistling like a
[ __ ] during the night time you
know so it's like where do they come
from i don't know it's like uh yeah like
i said step on the crack break break
your mother's back why okay i i and as a
kid i even i i was when i'd heard this i
was like no
that doesn't make any sense how fragile
is my mother's dog i was like i've
stepped on many cracks
intentionally after hearing this to test
the theory out um would i am i a bad
person probably if you go home your mind
is like riding on the ground oh no no no
no
everyone has collectively stepped on a
crack at some point isn't the earth just
one big crack that's it's just it's all
one big tectonic plate also what old
japan is a crown also what defines as a
crack like if i were to step on an ass
crack would i still break my mother's
back off
i'm pretty sure
for a second
how how amazing how this uh you know
scientific fact actually just rhymes as
well yeah wow
also uh but other stuff that i don't
really believe in anything like that and
even as a kid i remember that whenever i
heard these i was like no that doesn't
sound right what like a cat crossing
under an uh going under a ladder oh yeah
or a black cat crossing your path is bad
i think that's more like superstition
though that's a superstition yeah that's
what is this is
chugging a bunch of oranges not
superstition
i guess
they're all superstitions i don't know
if wait what is it what's the difference
what's the difference between a
superstition in an idiom
so um uh well idioms are more to explain
like it's
like an example uh raining cats and dogs
but oh yeah so yeah all of these okay
replace eating with superstitions yeah
yeah these are all superstitions so you
know i i guess it's superstitious of you
to consume a bunch of oranges in the
hope that it'll cure your illness right
that's superstitious
you have no no because it's it's
[ __ ]
because it's purely based on like
hearsay and information you've heard and
stuff yeah but but i feel like this is
yeah
it's so superstitious though right
that's what it originates from it's all
underneath that right
i feel like it's come from like
someone's experience that has been
passed down superstition feels more
like supernatural right where you know
like uh like opening up your umbrella
ins indoors is good it's bad luck i
don't know where that came from but like
at least like i don't do that anyway
because why would you do that yeah yeah
yeah opening indoors oh like what if
you're in like an umbrella store and you
want to test it out right
yeah they have umbrella stores
yeah in japan you never get to open it
though do you yeah you know what yeah
yeah i mean
i'm cracking that bad boy open yeah i
cracked that bad boy that's you know
come on i found my own house and then
every middle-aged woman in that store
looked at me like superstition
in japan though a lot of people do do
they really yeah a lot of people do i
feel like in asia the culture around
superstition is like very very prevalent
because everything everything is
superstitious
it has some kind of merit to it well
because everything like you know because
the whole belief system is very like
spiritual based right so i think a lot
of superstitions are more widely
believed there's like a i'd say a scale
of like yeah you're stepping on a crack
or break your mind yeah yeah yeah well
that's like the lower end of body yeah
yeah yeah whereas maybe i've heard this
from many people the vitamin c thing
yeah yeah which i i don't know if
there's any merit i don't know if it
does i don't know it's just like there
is some like really really basic logic
around it that you're like i can kind of
see that
like it's like i have this theory that
drinking water will help me feel better
and it's like you're right but i feel
like you're vastly
like over simple it's kind of like the
same thing with say you like your
experience with like manuka honey right
i'm just like yeah this is superstitious
yeah yeah yeah
i'm just like is there any science
behind that but like when i had when i
had kofi i was like [ __ ] spooning
these this manuka honey like nobody's
business it actually like helped my
throat
it felt it felt a lot
better what's it called what's called uh
the uh placebo yeah that's like a
placebo it could be which is like i'd
argue is a branch of the superstitious
tree because that's different placebo
placebo is the documented effect that it
actually has an effect yes
your your brain
is
making up for some form of [ __ ] thing
that you think placebo is so interesting
because it's like it hasn't been like
properly studied and a lot of scientists
reckon and like a lot of psychologists
reckon there is like something
legitimate there but we just don't know
what it is because we we don't we don't
know the [ __ ] because it's like we don't
know if it's actually a thing that works
or if it's just coincidence yeah like
well the placebo effect is that it does
work we just don't know how yeah we
don't
it's like the whole um remember the uh
life flashing before your eyes thing
yeah yeah yeah and how i was telling you
guys recently there was an article that
said they were scanning someone's brain
on on a table we're just collecting
scans we didn't talk about this on
podcast
taxi i remember this oh yeah
the superstitious we mentioned that in
the episode before i knew that but joey
didn't go on it for too long so i was
like i won't say anything yeah anyway
the guy was getting a scan a brain scan
right and
you know he's having a regular scanned
brain checking what's going on the brain
oh what's going on there and during this
generic scan that they were doing the
guy died of a heart attack and whilst
they were scanning him
while he was dying i assume they'd try
to help him i shouldn't just leave him
like now hold on let's just get him oh
this date is hold on hold on
um they did find out that apparently
right before he died it was the part of
his brain that was responsible for
memories was like firing like crazy yeah
which would although not proven because
it's only one instance it would back up
the theory that your life
at least all these memories start
flashing right yeah which is makes which
is one of those things where it's like
okay
i guess that makes sense because a lot
of people have said that it's happened
and yeah although there's no way to
solidly prove it but that's that's
until then it was not superstitious we
only have yeah we only have testimonies
from people who have been in like
near-death experiences yeah right right
like you know and then we have some kind
of not 100 percent proof but
some evidence to indicate that the
theory holds more work yeah yeah it's uh
we kill more people
basically like right before they just
like plug them out and just be like
quick get on the cat's game right now
edge
where they literally edged their life
the whole thing oh that was that was uh
outlining that
yeah yeah
yeah
i never saw that one that just sounded
like a dumb horror movie but not like
yeah i mean like oh
i wake up and i just saw jesus yeah i
remember like going back to like the
salt thing and uh just you're not you're
not gonna let this guarantee no because
because you just like talking about it
just reminded me about uh the time where
i kind of got an ulcer i believe and so
like have you you've had a mouth also
before yeah so how do you deal with it i
put like ulcer cream on it okay what do
what if you don't have ulcer cream like
what did i just don't try not to touch
it
toothpaste toothpaste i thought
toothpaste works
okay so like as a kid my mum was just
like oh just gargle salt water or like i
believe that does have some because yeah
if it's an inside the mouth you're
making
solutions it was like
i would always either
gargle salt water or um or gargle uh
sorry sorry sorry sorry sorry damn it
mouthwash
sorry i was like
i was i was legitimately right about to
say what you said i was like [ __ ]
how do we go from salt water to diesel
we have a million people who watch the
spotlight i'm so sorry i'm so sorry yeah
i would either like gargle
salt water or mouthwash and then one day
my ulcer was like so bad that uh the
salt water wasn't doing anything right
yeah so like as like a teenager i'm just
like what if uh what if uh instead of
just doing saltwater which is basically
just diluted soul what if i just go
straight to the source and this just
[ __ ] poor salt on it right
and uh that i swear to go that's uh so
that's what i did i i just i just like
got some like salt and just poured it
all all over this ulcer and it's [ __ ]
it's standing like nobody's [ __ ] it
sounds like it's not like [ __ ] hell
like burnt over in my mouth but then it
kind of numbs the wounds and i remember
waking up the next day and it was a lot
less painful it started healing straight
away now i don't know if there's any
science behind this i have googled it
and i know like some other people do it
as well uh but there's no like i don't
know if there's any back science behind
it but like
after that i started putting salt on my
ulcer whenever i get a mouth also and it
seemed to like
it seemed to heal it i'm sure there is
like some kind of science behind it but
like i feel that's like
probably the more extreme method of
things like you basically just napalmed
your mouth yeah the science says you're
completely wrong yeah yeah it could be
good so i remember one could also just
be a coincidence
yeah one day connor just come into the
office and complaining about a mouth
ulcer and i was like i have the perfect
solution
just walk into the kitchen
just pour a bunch of salt on it it's
it's easy condition i do it all the time
we do it all the time i remember coming
in him coming in like the next day or
something and he was like gone why did
you you literally just convinced me to
pour salt in a wound that's all you done
didn't help any it didn't i remember it
didn't help at all really just like it
stopped the pain for like two hours
in exchange for like one burst of
immense pain yeah but like it didn't do
anything you basically just pre-ordered
i think that gantt would have healed
naturally without the soul and i think
he just poured saul and happens to
remember that it then went away
basically just didn't like also hardcore
it doesn't hurt enough illnesses that go
away yeah right like you know obviously
in very serious illnesses the
pseudoscience is uh very harmful yeah
and very [ __ ] up that people try and
sell solutions that are like you know
they'll be like just take our herbs and
your cancer will go yeah like that's
[ __ ] up yeah you're even telling
people that yeah but
i think the reason why with generic
illnesses so many superstitions come
about is because they go anyway on their
own and if you're doing [ __ ] and it
happens to go away you're probably your
mind is aha
i was sick one time and then i i i
played with my poop for 20 minutes in my
hands like play-doh and it went away the
next day and it's like well no that's
there now i've got three other illnesses
but uh i didn't lose the flu you know
it's like
you can do things
anything yeah do it every single time
you get sick with a generic illness that
will go away anyway after 48 hours yeah
and then you'll remember that you did
that thing and then it went away yeah so
this probably happened with like the
vitamin c you probably maybe have a
little bit of placebo effect as well and
then boom it goes away and you're like
well it must be vitamin c because every
time i take vitamin c my cold goes as if
you did nothing your vitamin c wouldn't
go away but it it's not how it works it
would go away anyway but i want like an
experiment of like especially with the
vitamin c thing of like catch a call one
time do the vitamin c thing and then
catch a call the second time but don't
do the vitamin c thing which one you
killed you need to do this like a
hundred times to get any data worth
considering well there's plenty of sick
people today
it wouldn't matter because we could just
like view the immune system anyway with
the things that we do we're gonna
dedicate my whole life to see if oranges
work during the floor turns out we don't
know yeah science sucks because science
is boring as [ __ ] yeah it takes a long
time and people don't like that yeah
unfortunately maybe we can make it they
want results now yeah of course it's
like yeah maybe we can we can go to
another planet in 200 years it's like oh
[ __ ] i'm not going to be around for that
so something yeah
that's the problem back back to humans
are just so incapable of like really
caring about things that happen in like
the far future and like overwhelming
there's a reason why we're so [ __ ] with
it
it's not gonna affect me tomorrow so i
was [ __ ] whatever yeah i mean like i
mean we've talked about something
similar before where like talking about
just imagining five years in the future
or like where you're going to be five
years or ten years in the future can you
imagine what 2027 is going to be like no
yeah because everyone thought in 2012
that 2022 is like yeah flying cars right
i couldn't imagine being 30 and here i
am for 31 like how the [ __ ] did that
happen
i basically did i'm basically dead
i think it's same with that exercise
right like i can't i i know exercise is
good for me yeah and i like it when i do
it yeah yeah but i just can't
i can't visualize the benefits to my
life exactly yeah yeah that's why it's
so hard to maintain yeah that's why it's
so hard to keep it up even though i feel
amazing when i do it i normally have so
much energy i feel great i know and i
can feel the immediate tangible benefits
yeah but for some reason i just can't
convince myself long term that i can
visualize
that hey when i'm 70 maybe i'll be a lot
better off for it if i just put in the
work now even not even that it's just
like you know you you could be like yeah
you could be like working out right and
like a week later you'd look down your
body and be like why do i still look
exactly the same that yeah that's as
well dude that's like it's it's it blows
you get that pump on you you go hard and
you're like why why but then you eat
like two weeks of mcdonald's and you're
like wow nothing changed amazing which
you love it you love that nothing
changes but then you get angry when it
doesn't change
we suck as humans i know yeah that's
that's what sucks right is that if if
you want to gain weight fast oh look it
get ripped fast you also have to accept
the fact that maybe one binge drinking
weekend yeah [ __ ] your body today